[Music]
[Music]
it's here
oh yeah oh my goodness yeah it's amazing
selena gomez just dropped her new
spanish single de una vez
and the video is all kinds of dreamy
oh thank you
[Music]
the singer shared a snippet of the video
on instagram alongside a caption
in spanish which she translated to
english
quote de una vez is out now this is the
beginning of something i've wanted to
explore
for so long i hope you love it as much
as i do
[Music]
the 28 year old who is of mexican
descent has been
outspoken about embracing her heritage
in her new music
and enlisted popular latin creators to
help
including grammy-winning producer tiny
albert hype
hota rosa and neon 16. she also worked
with the creative duo los perez to
direct the accompanying music video
this marks selena's first song in
spanish since 2018's takitaki
[Music]
and this is her first solo spanish
language project since 2014's
moss offer album for you
the triple threat recently opened up to
apple music's zane lowe about the song's
release
and revealed that she's wanted to do a
spanish project for 10 years
and the pandemic lockdown gave her the
time she needed
to do it quote i feel like it's the
perfect timing just with all the
division in the world there's something
about latin music that globally just
makes people feel things you know
selena added that she actually thinks
she sings better in spanish
but it wasn't easy quote i just hope
that people understand how much i put my
heart into this and how amazing i feel
about it